if anything undoes this this will be it
that our languages failed that we
misread each other's intent that we
could not understand each other so the
the project of refining language is is
the same project as the ending of
history I mean history is the story of
languages that fail and when language
grows perfect history will end and
they've made light which may not look
like it looks today or sound like it
sounds today
the realization that's flowered in the
wake of the internet and the rise of
cybernetics is that everything is made
of information information is the
primary method of being concepts like
time and space and energy are orders of
magnitude removed from the present at
hand when compared with a concept like
information every aisle to every bit of
information that passes through us that
we generate that we transmit changes us
so I'm seeing here almost the
Theosophical epiphany of language trying
to bootstrap itself toward realms of
platonic perfection which as organic
being we experience as love love beauty
truth these are the vectors of human
becoming they always have been they
always will be and the technologies that
both of these paths for us are no more
and no less powerful than the human
beings that wheel so you know this is
this is an enterprise of integrity and
millennial implication and what life as
the goal is true human in sympathetic
symbiosis with the planet and with these
strange children that we have brought
into the world are machines I mean that
is the challenge at the end of history
we are somehow told we are infant alized
we're told you know you can wander
around within the sanctioned playpen of
ordinary consciousness and we have some
intoxicants over here if you want to
mess yourself up we've got some Scotch
here and tobacco and red sugar in the
little TV so forth and so on
but but these boundary dissolving how a
sentence that give you a sense of unity
with your fellow man and nature are
somehow forbidden this is an outrage
it's a sign of cultural immaturity and
the fact that we tolerate it is a sign
that we are
living in a society is oppressed as any
society in the past
my thing is not about my opinion or what
I saw in Africa or anything like this is
get it straight this is about an
experience not my experience your
experience isn't about an experience
which you have like getting laid there
like going to Africa you must do the
experience otherwise it's it's just
whistling past the graveyard and we're
not talking about something like being
born again or meeting the flying saucers
or something like that we're good works
and prayer are in the method know if you
take a sufficient dose of an active
compound it will deliver itself to you
on the money if it doesn't work take no
is in a position to dismiss this just
because it didn't work for them on one
or two tries this is an art it's an art
of something you coax into existence you
have to learn to make love you have to
learn to speak English anything worth
doing is an art that is acquired this is
part of our birthright perhaps the most
important part of our birthright these
substances will deliver it is the
confinement of psychology and science
generally and that's why it's so touchy
for cultural institutions but you are
not a cultural institution you are a
free and independent human being these
things have your name written on them in
big gold letters
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]